hi
my name is alan gerber and i'm the
director of the institution for social
and policy studies
the sponsor of tonight's event tonight
we're going to be having a
panel discussion excuse me a few
speakers followed by question and answer
period
the topic for tonight's session is what
did the voters do
and why did they do it and so for this
event we've gathered
four experts on political behavior
american political behavior
to put what happened uh on election day
and after election day into into
perspective
and shed some light on the science of
the study
and understanding of voter behavior uh
tonight we're going to have a question
and answer period and here are some of
the logistics associated with
that and the rest of the event uh please
send
questions uh to the panelists
using the question and answer button at
the bottom of the zoom
screen uh the questions ideally should
be
relatively short so please try
not to write a paragraph if you think
you can write
maybe a sentence or a sentence and a
half it'll be a lot easier for us to
process those questions
the event is being recorded uh if you
need technical assistance
uh please email isps
yale.edu so that's isps.yale.edu
and here's the format for tonight's
event
um following my introductory welcoming
remarks
and biographical details about tonight's
panelists
each of the panelists will talk for
about seven minutes
uh sharing a few of their uh critical
insights their key insights about the
election with you
uh and then we're gonna have a question
and answer period so
uh you can start sending your questions
along whenever whenever you
you have them and they'll be gathered up
and and i'll i'll
ask them of the uh of the panelists
uh after their remarks have concluded
uh and we'll go that'll that part of the
session will go in about 30
30 minutes we i would imagine great
so tonight let me now begin uh welcoming
the panelists in order of their
appearance they're going to be
speaking in alphabetical order uh we're
going to begin with
alex kopick alex is an assistant
professor of political science at yale
and a resident faculty fellow at the
institution of social and policy studies
and center for the study of american
politics
and alex's research lies at the
lies in uh the study of political
persuasion and its implications
for the malleability of public opinion
in the context of elections
he's an expert on the design and
analysis of randomized experiments
and he won the best software award for
declare design
and that was awarded by the american
political science association political
methodology section
in 2019 alex
is working on two books now one on
research design
and one on persuasion if you're
interested you can check out some of
alex's scholarship
one of his recent papers in science
advances is on
the subject he'll be talking about in
his remarks
that's a paper called the small effects
of political advertising
are small regardless of context message
sender or receiver evidence from 59
real-time randomized experiments
so you can check that out and other
other of alex's works
next we'll be hearing from josh calla
josh is also an assistant professor of
political science
at yale he's also a professor in the
department of statistics and data
science
he's a resident fellow at the
institution for social and policy
studies
josh studies political persuasion
prejudice reduction
and decision-making among voters and
political elites
primarily through the use of field
experiments
calla was awarded the lemur rosenthal
prize for open social science
and his work has also been awarded the
kaldini prize
by the society for personality and
social psychology
an award that recognizes the publication
that best explicates social
psychological phenomena
principally through the use of field
research methods
josh josh's scholarship has been
published in
numerous academic journals if you're
interested in reading more
check out reducing exclusionary
attitudes through interpersonal
conversation published
in a recent issue of the american
political science review
welcome welcome josh
next we'll hear from mike pothauser
mike is assistant to the president for
strategic research
at the afl-cio he's a leading political
strategist and analyst
for over 30 decades and has led the
federation strategy to create
permanent year-round mobilization
capacity to elect worker-friendly
candidates
advocates for issues and demand greater
accountability from elected officials
independent from political party
structures he established working
america
a community partner organization that
has grown
to 3 million non-union members
nationwide reflecting focus on all
working families
whether or not they are covered by
collective bargaining
pot hauser led the federation's work on
voter protection efforts
and voter mobilization strategy during
the most recent election
he is a recognized leader in his field
and he was also a pioneer in data-driven
politics
and is uh admired by by all those
who um who are interested in the uh
in the science of voter behavior and
then we'll be hearing from
uh oh i should also say he was a one of
the founding chairs of the analyst
institute
uh one of the leading organizations for
uh
bringing science to campaign activity
and then we'll be hearing from lynn
vavrek
lynn is the marvin hoffenberg professor
of american politics
and public policy at ucla she was
pi of the 2020 election project
nationscape
the largest study of presidential
elections ever fielded in the united
states
the project has been interviewing more
than 6 000 people a week
and will complete 500 000 interviews
before the inauguration in 2021
are you still in the field
great that's that's really good to hear
because there's
this was one of those elections where
you were wondering if it would end
and so it was great that you're still on
the field did you did you decide that
before
before the election okay yeah through
inauguration day yeah that's pressing
question yeah very good uh lynn was a
recipient
of the andrew carnegie prize one of the
kind of big fellowship awards in the
social sciences
and i don't know if it helped fund the
research that i just described or not
but
it probably funded some important
studies that you've conducted
lynn is the author of five books
including identity crisis the 2016
presidential campaign
and the battle for the meaning of
america described as the most ominous
book
on the 2016 election
lin is also a contributing columnist to
the upshot at the new york times
lin is a leading scholar of american
politics and american elections
and it's wonderful that she's here
joining us from los angeles tonight
um with that why don't we just turn it
over to our panelists
uh they will speak without interruption
uh in between their
their talks alex josh mike and lynn
in that order and then we'll we'll open
it up for question and answer
thank you very much
thank you alan thanks everyone for
joining tonight
um the paper that alan referenced is
that the small effects of political
advertising are small
and it has two smalls in the title which
was like the editor of the journal was
like are you sure there's not a typo
here
like no no the small effects of
political advertising are indeed small
uh regardless of all of the things in
the title so
context and the kind of person you are
and the time of the election so that's
what that paper
that paper finds and i'd love to talk
more about that but i actually prepared
um
a a different topic for you which was
it's about the
pre-election polls and the difference
between the pre-election polls and what
actually occurred and so the source of
biases
in the polls are something that we need
to shake out as a community
we need to figure out why it is we are
unable to
seem to estimate with um as much
accuracy as we would like
what the vote margins are going to be
and i want to talk about
one source of bias that i actually don't
think is a problem
and it comes up a lot which is this idea
that some people when we get them in the
interview
we ask them who they're going to vote
for and they are embarrassed or they're
worried that they will experience shame
if they admit who they're going to vote
for and this happened in particular with
respect
or the idea is that it happened in
particular with respect to trump voters
so uh because donald trump is associated
with racist and sexist views
people who are trump supporters were
worried that if they admitted
in a survey that they are a trump
supporter that they would themselves be
seen
as racist or sexist so that's that's
an example of sensitivity bias so if a
question is sensitive it's because
i think that if i say my true answer
that i will experience
some cost perhaps in embarrassment or
other things and sensitivity biases is a
real thing
so like in authoritarian regimes if
that we can demonstrate that people over
report support for authoritarian regimes
because
perhaps rightly they expect bad
consequences
if it is found out that they don't
support the regime so we know that
through
through these techniques that indirectly
estimate
uh support for the regime or in this
case
indirectly estimate support for
donald trump so in the 2016 cycle i did
a thing called a list experiment and
this list experiment is an
indirect method of estimating uh support
for a candidate that doesn't require a
person
to directly admit
their true beliefs but they can let us
know in another way and i'm going to
share my screen to show you example of
what
what that experiment looked like
so what we did is we split the uh
a sample of circuit respondents into two
groups a control group and a treatment
group
and the control group was asked the
question on the left so please tell me
how many of these following things you
would do
we don't know what we don't want to know
which of them you would do just how
money
so the list is if it were up for a vote
i would vote to raise the minimum wage
if it were up for a vote i would vote to
repeal the affordable care act
if it were up for a vote i would vote to
ban assault weapons so we don't say
which of those things you would do you
just say how many so perhaps your answer
is two
if you were assigned to the treatment
group you saw those same three things
plus a fourth item
if the 2016 presidential election were
being held today and the candidates were
clinton and trump i would vote for trump
and so if you then say two i don't know
whether you would
vote for donald trump or you would do
one of these other things so this is a
way in which we
protect survey respondents identity if
we then take the average difference
between the treatment and control group
that forms an estimate
of the fraction who support donald trump
okay so
cat's out of bed when i did this i found
no difference
none between the list experiment
estimate
and the direct question estimates so
this indirect thing which made it so
that people didn't have to directly
admit and be embarrassed about their
support for donald trump
it didn't change our estimate of the
support for donald trump
so if we look on the left we have strong
democrats
the the small dot is the direct question
estimate the depth with the big whiskers
that's the effect um from the list
experiment and we can see that since the
confidence levels
overlap it's approximately the same
answer right
and that pattern persists for all seven
flavors of party identification that we
measure
in this experiment so i established in
the 2016 election
that i don't think that shy trump
supporters the sensitivity bias with
respect to the presidential vote choice
question
is a major source of bias i didn't do it
again in 2020 but there are other clues
that sensitivity bias is
not a major factor in explaining the
polling mess
so on the left-hand side so this facet
the presidential facet this is not a
graphic that i made this is
made by uh thomas wood who's um just an
unbelievable
data visualizer i'm in awe of what he's
able to do so quickly
he was making graphs like this on on
election night
in each state we're seeing the
pre-election polls minus the actual
vote totals in each state and we see
that over here
we are getting really bad uh we're
missing by 15 points in biden's
direction
what we can see for sensitivity bias is
that we miss the same states for senate
that we miss
for the presidential so if people are
uncomfortable
you'd have to believe that they're also
uncomfortable admitting their support
for susan collins
as they are uncomfortable so admitting
their support
for trump and we don't think that that's
the case right so what we think instead
it's not once we get them in the survey
are they lying to us
the problem is before then the problem
is we're not reaching
the right people and so with response
rates what they are
we're having to do all the statistical
wizardry to try and reweight
the polls in order to get a more
accurate picture of what's going to
happen on election day
and for two election cycles in a row our
rewaiting
strategy has not been successful now i'm
in the privileged position of not having
to actually do that hard work myself so
i'm throwing stones
but i don't think it's because of
sensitivity bias i think that it's
due to selection into the sample so
that's all i have for you
i think josh you're up next
thank you so much alex for for opening
that up
and thank you all for joining us uh
taking time out of your evening to
to come listen to us talk about the
world of politics
so today i want to talk about
um what i think matters in presidential
campaigns and how this sometimes
differs from what some analysts what
some talking heads say and
it also supports what other analysts and
other talking head station i want to
kind of
seek a claim in this argument as to what
matters in presidential campaigns
and to illustrate the next few minutes i
just want to use the example of
taxes everything that i'm going to say
you could apply in different states you
could apply to different candidates and
presidential races
but texas is a nice example coming out
of the 2020 election
and one of the big questions i have been
asked is why did joe biden
lose ground with latinos in south texas
and more broadly
why did joe biden lose texas and
coming out of the race you see two very
competing
explanations and the texas monthly has
done a nice job
interviewing folks on the ground and
trying to get their their
interpretations of the race
and reading kind of the popular press
version of the election you see very
two competing arguments and one is
exemplified nicely by
um chuck rocha who used to work for
senator sanders and now runs an
organization trying to organize latino
voters
and what chuck says is it's really a
matter of campaign tactics he's quoted
as saying that
the reason why joe biden lost in texas
is quote nobody was knocking on people's
doors
and letting them know why they should
vote for biden and that's kind of one
very common argument you see throughout
the presidential election uh it's all
about tactics if biden had done more of
x or if trump had done more of x
they would have won rather than someone
else on the other side you see an
argument where it's not about
tactics it's very much one about
messaging and
this i think is explained nicely by
joaquin hernandez who
used to run a local republican
organization in texas
and here he's quoted as saying i think
trump kind of hit it right on the head
for people
here with the drain the swamp message
because the valley has been riddled by
corruption
people here have seen how year after
year at least one elected democratic
official locally has been indicted for
bribery or corruption
i also think that riots and calls to
defund the police turned off a lot of
people who are normally maybe moderate
or conservative democrats
and come from law enforcement families
who are just appalled by that kind of
message
so this is very much a debate of
campaign tactics campaign contact
versus messaging and we as social
scientists actually
know a lot about this debate and many
people on this panel have
written a lot of research on this debate
so i'm going to be citing most of the
um most of the the research from from
other panelists and
hopefully i get them right and hopefully
they agree with my interpretation
but professor gerber has done really
path-breaking work on
what we know about the effective
campaign tactics on the ability to
increase voter turnout and if you're
interested in this topic he has a
fantastic book with professor greene
called get out the vote which goes
through all of the social science all
the evidence that we know
on ways to increase voter turnout and
what they find in this book is that in
high salience elections
such as presidential races for every
1000
conversations a campaign has they're
able to generate about
seven additional votes and
in practice a campaign needs to knock on
about three doors in order to have
one conversation so we can do the back
of the envelope map then we can ask
ourselves
if joe biden just knocked on more doors
in texas would he have been able
to win and to kind of put the cart
before the horse answer the answer is no
um so to go through the math in order to
have one texas through mobilization
through increasing turnout
joe biden would have needed to mobilize
630 000
additional votes and this would have
required around 4.4
million conversations which would have
required knocking on around 13.2 million
doors
and unfortunately for the biden campaign
there were only about
seven and a half million eligible voters
in texas who did not vote in
2020 so there just aren't enough of
these voters for
additional campaign contact additional
campaign conversations
to really make a meaningful difference
in overturning
this particular election result and we
can think about a different way
campaigns might be effective and that is
through persuasion
and this is something i've written a
little bit about and in my research
we find that for every 1 000
conversations
a campaign has they're able to persuade
around
six additional posts they're able to
generate about six additional votes
through persuasion
and in order to have won texas through
persuasion the biden campaign would have
needed to get
320 000 trump voters to instead become
guided voters so we can again go through
that back of the envelope map
and see that this would have required
around 1.9 million conversations
5.8 million door knocks and
unfortunately there were only about 5.9
million trump voters
in texas and we can also think about the
work that um professors copic and fabric
along with professor hill have done
on the small effects of political
advertising are small regardless of
context message sender or receiver
because of these small persuasive
effects there just often aren't enough
voters to have a meaningful impact when
it comes to
presidential races so i think from what
we know about
the science of campaign outreach it's
just that
more campaign outreach often isn't
sufficient to change
election results in presidential
elections in swing states
um i used texas as an example but we
could apply this back of the envelope
math to other states and come up with a
very similar conclusion that there's
just
limited effects of this outreach and not
large enough effects to
meaningfully change these types of
presidential election results
i do want to just like raise a very
important caveat which is if you do this
kind of work if you volunteer if you
work for an organization who does this
kind of work
your efforts still can make a very big
difference
because some elections are really close
and the evidence that we have is that
there are larger effects in primaries
local races and ballot measures so if
you
do this kind of volunteer work double
down in those types of primaries local
races and ballot measures because
that's where the back of the envelope
math is is much more favorable
so what does matter in presidential
campaigns if it's not
additional campaign contact additional
campaign outreach and here i want to
point to
a really influential book that professor
maverick wrote
called the message matters and professor
maverick isn't paying me to say this
this is not a paid endorsement but this
is a really influential book and if
you're interested in understanding
presidential campaigns i highly
recommend
checking it out and the title does a
nice job capturing
what matters it's presidential it's the
messaging
and professor vavrek um lays out some
predictions as to
what kind of messaging campaigns ought
to be using and she
talks about two situations one where the
economy is good one where the economy is
bad
and when the economy is good we should
expect the incumbent to focus
his or her campaign message on the
economy champion
championing the fact that the economy is
good thus you should re-elect this
candidate
and for the challenger they obviously
don't want to talk about the economy
that helps the the incumbent instead
they should focus their campaign message
on
some other popular issue where they are
more popular than the incumbent
the incumbent is stuck in an unpopular
position and this other issue is or can
be made
important and when the economy is bad we
would expect the the opposite prediction
and professor babrick has a really nice
conclusion where she says
candidates who violate these
prescriptions these predictions lose
elections
and by kind of inverse when they follow
these prescriptions they win
elections so it's really about not these
individual campaign
tactics but these broader meta-narrative
points about the messaging about
are you focusing on the economy if the
economy is good for your incumbent
or are you focusing on some other
popular issue if you can't talk about
the economy
and this idea of messaging really needs
to be talked more about and taken
seriously
and i think really helps us understand
presidential election results so thank
you all so much and i look forward to
the rest of the panel
there we go thank you um i have to say
that
um really feel a little bit
out of place as um i
um sort of come to this from a somewhat
different perspective
and being very much about the
practice of politics and the odd thing
in listening to the
last two speakers is that i may actually
believe that campaign matter
campaigns generally matter even less um
the
even though that's what i've just been
like has um
alan said 300 decades doing um
the um so and i really want to take on a
lot of what just said but instead i'll
do what i was going to
start out doing um which is sort of do a
sort of
um broader sweep on all of this um
so imagine that um the united states
were 100 people
um and on november 8th 2016
51 of them um voted for hillary clinton
49 of them voted for donald trump um
you then had now over 100 200 a quarter
million people did a covet
30 million people were unemployed racial
justice movements impeachment
all of that stuff you end up spending um
outspending trump by three to two with
14 billion dollars
and 1x moves from the
republican side to the democratic side
that's it that's what happened over the
last four years that is it
right you're in a room with 100 people
and what happened was one person across
the
other side of the room after spending 14
billion dollars
um so what had that happened um
we had saw unprecedented political
engagement
four years as i said of like insane
dislocation
um uncertainty that none of us have
really experienced in our lifetimes
and almost no change in our political
choices
um which has to lead to kind of
epistemological angst like we don't know
what the [ __ ] is happening in this world
um so just to run through that so in
turn to really get us in this is
the the level of increase in civic
engagement
is like hasn't happened it just hasn't
happened
right the last two cycles um if you look
on the right
right it's things like people coming
home from world war ii that saw the same
kind of
um increase in turnout right trump
is like a political noise machine he
makes every election the super bowl
and what that means is that just like
the super bowl
people don't even watch a game during
the season show up for the party
and that's what happened in 18 that's
what happened now
it's like incredible engagement
he's the most unpopular president in a
way that again you just have to really
like have to see stuff like this to
comprehend
right the only president who never had
a month where he was above water there
hasn't been a
like period since he announced that more
people wanted him to be president than
didn't
um that his approval ratings despite all
this
uh turmoil stayed you know with a
standard deviation
that other than eisenhower is like
completely out of whack
um and the structure of the race never
changed right from
2016. it's like the people were
organized around
trump that was it people who had voted
for one of the two and 16
not many of them moved and the movement
was always toward
a little bit of movement net towards the
democrats
because it was a lincoln project no
roosevelt project
the johnson stein voters there wasn't a
poll where um
the democratic margin was uh less than
10
28 midterm voters 20 points so like that
sort of fueled our sense that the people
were moving away from trump to a greater
extent
which led to these kind of crazy things
um with
you know 90 percent chance he's going to
win 347 electoral votes
uh more than twice as many electoral uh
popular vote margin so i'm just putting
the numbers up here see
like i'm sure like have some semblance
of not making this up
the basic thought experiment um in the
first rows just like the 2016 election
is pretty much
for three of the folks on the uh panel
who've like read me
writing about this ahead of time this
isn't like post hoc
right so you have one um so basically
you have
the 2016 voters were 2.2
for um clinton um the people who vote in
2018
were 22 points for the house democrats
which meant the people who came back
from the 16 were five points um
uh democratic and overall it was a 7.4
point
everything looked like completely
consistent with the story
all of us wanted to know which is people
were done with trump they were moving
away
all that which made the polls seem more
reasonable so i did a thing where i
looked at it two ways one is assume
that all the people who vote in 2016
really didn't change their mind
and if they didn't change their mind and
the people who showed up in 2018 didn't
show up the mine
then the 2020 election should be four
and a half points spread which is what
it actually is
um or the people who showed up and were
5.1 uh for democrats were actually
reflective of
clinton voters uh 2016 voters and it
should have been seven points
um there's a lot of it should actually
be a little bit less if
you do fancier math but that's basically
the order magnitude so the polls were
like which were above that
like we're living in a world that
couldn't exist um
but that was sort of what was going on i
thought ahead of time six was going to
be
it um but that's that's sort of what was
real
um and as and but that fed our our
willingness to believe polls that were
telling us something very very different
right because we've just seen democrats
win these big victories in 2018
we saw a polling that we liked and all
that
um but i would argue that polling can't
be fixed at all
when trump is on the ballot um because
um the there's no there are no shy trump
voters in fact if you've ever been in a
room with one
that seems like a silly concept um the
right naga hats the whole thing who are
they um
but they don't like to take polls and
the
not because necessarily they think
they're a democratic plot
but that's just not who they are right
so imagine
dave the backhoe driver in michigan
right who's never thought that there was
a candidate like trump to vote for
before and never showed up
when he decides wow trump's the real
deal and i'm going to go out and vote
he doesn't realize that he also has to
get on a yougov panel or a lucid panel
or something like that so the rest of us
know that he's part of the electorate
and is going to turn out in 2020
which is why the polls were right on in
2018 not on at all in 2020.
um the but that was that's a lot of
what's going on and you can't fix that
because in 2016 people wanted to believe
it was this white non-college thing but
i don't have enough time to say well
that's really pernicious and wrong and
bad
but it's not right it didn't work um
it's really just people
who like trump do not like polls that
correlation it's not a demographic thing
it's just who they are and all that and
the second thing though which is like
more in some ways more important is that
the polls fail to do that
but we also failed to just use common
sense the
um for people that really are engaged in
politics and believed it
because it's like we've become sort of
society
that wants to know um what the weather
is and checks our app
instead of going outside and seeing
what's going on um
and that's what the polling was we were
just like looking at these stats
without like actually going out and
looking at what was happening in the
world
so again have the receipts over the
summer just thought well this is not
right
looked at two things one was voter
registration white non-college
off the chart um democratic-based groups
depressed
right clear signal was coming then you
get to early vote
big campaign to get bay democratic base
voters to vote early
no campaign to get white not college
white non-college among non-voters is
keeping pace
or in exceeding democratic base groups
who had 200
billion dollars thrown at them to go
vote by mail right all of which is
saying
polls that are saying the opposite can't
possibly be right
um and so that basically leaves you in a
place where
like you just can't depend on the polls
and uh i think i'm gonna start with time
but to wrap up
if you really step back and we're like
clicking too much on 538
or reading all these what would all this
stuff was narrating noise
in the polls right we were getting
stories about seniors doing this and
that doing this and all of that
to just account for statistical noise
and for these errors
right if as a practitioner on november
9th 2016 i knew arizona um michigan
uh pennsylvania wisconsin arizona were
going to be key
thought nevada was florida wasn't didn't
see georgia
didn't need a single poll for the red
for the next four years
um and if i had them i thought florida
was in play i thought north carolina was
in play
all of these things that were illusions
um so i think that's time
and i'll stop there
all right i think i am next and i am
also going to share
some uh visuals with you um
it is a pleasure to be here uh virtually
in new haven with
all of these people from whom i have
learned so much
over my career um and i'm going to just
talk
briefly about how i think about what
happened
in 2020 um so
i like to think about presidential
elections as having
two components the big things and these
are the things that
always matter every presidential
election they affect vote choice
these are things like party
identification the state
of the nation's economy josh has told
you a little bit about my
my messaging work surrounding the
economy we're going to talk about that a
little more
so that's the first set and the second
set are the things that i call
the swing things so things that
happen maybe in one election but not in
another election
this might be who the candidates are it
might be the messaging that they choose
to focus on
it might be whether there's a global
pandemic happening whether there's a
global financial
crisis so things that you can't count on
happening every single year so big
things
and swing things and we're going to talk
about a few things in each set
in the next couple of minutes so the
first
big thing i mentioned is party
identification and the way that i want
everyone to think about party
identification is that it is strong
and stable strong because
most people in the country most people
who turn up to vote in elections
have a party identification with one of
the two major american political parties
maybe 10 percent somewhere around 10
percent of the electorate
uh probably less than that will consider
themselves
to be truly independent of party and not
even say they lean
when you push them so almost everyone
has a party identification
and then conditional on having one of
those party ids
people pretty much vote for the
candidate that is in their party
so for example in 2020 about 86 percent
of
people who call themselves republicans
voted for donald trump
90 of people who call themselves
democrats oh sorry
that should say voted for joe biden not
hillary clinton
um so the robust effect of party
identification
on vote choice so those numbers are
really big they're close to 90 percent
they are like that
every presidential election plus or
minus two or three
points that's a lot of people doing what
we can predict they're going to do
a long time in advance people's party
identifications rarely
change so if you're a republican last
time you're probably still a republican
this time
so that means that the number of people
who can
swing elections is a small set
but it's an important and pivotal set
and so we want to think about that
okay a second big factor that matters
every year
is the state of the nation's economy and
as
josh mentioned earlier i have spent a
lot of time thinking about
how important this is in every
presidential election
and how it sets the stage for
presidential campaigns it isn't the play
but it's the stage dressing it tells you
whether we're watching a comedy or a
drama
so what i'm showing you here is just a
little bit of evidence about
how robust the effect of the nation's
economy
is on presidential election outcomes
on the horizontal axis here i'm showing
you
change in the nation's economy gdp uh
growth let's call it um in the first six
months of an election year
january to june of every election year
the year markers here are plotting
symbols indicating the
presidential election on the y-axis
i'm showing you the incumbent party's
share of the two-party vote
in these elections and i've drawn a line
here that's
sort of the line of best fit through
these plotting symbols
and you can see that it slopes upward
what does that tell us
it tells us that as gdp is increasing
in the six months of an election year so
growth is positive
incumbent parties do better when growth
is negative
incumbent parties do worse so incumbent
parties and growing economies typically
win and incumbent parties and shrinking
economies
typically lose and i've highlighted here
2020 for you
if you're curious right here is 2016
almost exactly on the
the prediction line here's
and you can see trump is over performing
his economy but it is the worst
economy in terms of gdp growth that
we've seen since the new deal
so out here with 1980 and and jimmy
carter's re-election
but 2020 is kind of unique and i want to
show you
a little bit about why the state of the
nation's economy is a little complicated
because of the stimulus payments so on
the left side here is the graph i just
showed you
this is gdp growth but on the right hand
side
same y-axis same vertical axis but now
i'm showing you growth rate of real
disposable income per capita
january to june and this is you see the
same trend
right rdi goes up people have more money
in their pockets it's better for the
incumbent
okay but here's 2020 it is
now the best performing rdi
economic elections since the new deal so
2020 presents this
national context this economic context
to people
where the nation's economy is shrinking
and quickly and in a very
um sort of scary way but in terms of
how much money people have available
they have
more than in any previous presidential
election year
so this is a little bit of a unique
situation there aren't a lot of other if
you look at 1980
here's the other um bad growth year and
and rdi is also shrinking
uh here's global financial crisis so
it's unusual to have
an election that sort of is the worst
and the best
on two different economic indicators so
that's gonna maybe complicate the role
of the economy
in 2020 but maybe not let's see so what
kind of a swing now let's move to things
that swing what kind of a swing did we
have
in 2020 so i'm showing you here
states and obama's two-party vote margin
in 2012.
on the horizontal axis and then in 2016
on the vertical axis
right so he's the same guy running in
each one of these elections
and you can see that these states are
performing differently
in 12 then in 2016. some states
he's doing better in 2016 texas arizona
california i'm sorry not he's not the
same it's clinton again
well i really have a problem identifying
which elections uh she's running it
right so 2016. this is obama in 12 to
clinton in 16.
she's over performing him in california
arizona and texas
and underperforming in ohio and iowa
and now you can so this is sort of a
jagged pattern here some states better
some states worse
let's look at the swing from 16 to 20.
and you can see that this looks a little
different um some of these states were
still counting when i
when i made this figure so uh they have
tightened up closer to the line but you
can see
almost all the states have swung toward
joe biden
in 2020 and almost by the same amount
so this is what we would call more of a
uniform swing
there is something about 2020 in
relation
to 2016 that is pushing everybody in the
country in the same direction
and when you compare the difference in
12 to 16 there's not that same uniform
swing here some states are going more
democratic
some are going more republican so we
want to think about
what is driving this uniform swing
and is it something about the campaign
is it something about the election year
prime candidate covid identity politics
um all of these things are potential
candidates
so i'll tell you just quickly about some
of the work that i've done
to try to figure out what's driving the
shifts
turnout is a big part of this story so
let's just stipulate
um that that's a big component michael
just told you a little bit about
how that might work i'm interested in
the switching
the persuasion that josh uh was talking
about and
how much of that we can see happening
from 16 to 20.
so partisans come home that's the first
story it is not surprising
that's the stable feature party
identification
um if you were a democrat who voted for
donald trump in 2016
you were more likely to come home to the
democratic party in 2020
there isn't a lot of cross-party
switching
independents are going to switch more to
joe biden
than they are switching to donald trump
so i'm using
now my massive data collection that alan
told you about in the beginning
so if you were an independent um in 2016
and uh in 2020 you are more likely to
switch your vote
to joe biden than you are to switch to
donald trump so independents are moving
toward biden
but i want to just say something about
kovit kovitt is a player here and it is
i think
the feature of 2020 that is most going
to define the outcome of this
election close as it was as michael just
said
so 87 of americans say they are very or
somewhat concerned with the coronavirus
and that number it concern is declining
but it isn't declining a lot that's a
pretty robust number across the entire
um several months of the crisis of the
pandemic
and concern about covid is associated
with switching disproportionately
to joe biden and let me just show you
one
uh table that will illustrate that
what i'm showing you here are trump
voters from 2016. so these are people
who in my survey tell me they voted for
donald trump
in 2016. and i'm showing you across the
top here
the distribution of coveted concern for
those people
so 46 percent of trump 2016 voters say
i'm very concerned about coronavirus 34
say i'm somewhat concerned about
coronavirus that's
a lot of people if you add those two
numbers together
those people are switching in 2020 to
vote
for for joe biden i'm showing you here
did they stay with trump or did they
switch to biden
and you can see 15 of nearly
these these 46 percent of trump voters
who are very concerned
are switching to biden and six percent
of the 34
who are somewhat concerned so that's a
lot of people who are worried about the
virus
switching to biden the same is not true
for clinton voters in 16.
most of them are also concerned about
coronavirus but the big
switching to trump is happening here
where nobody
nobody lives here very few clinton
voters are
not concerned or not at all concerned
about coronavirus
and those are the people who are
switching to trump there's not a lot of
switching among people who are worried
and so i have done this kind of
switching analysis
for a number of things for racial
attitudes
there's some small effects there for
worried about
losing your job and and the economy
there are some small effects there
but these covid and coronavirus concern
numbers are the biggest
in terms of the things that are pushing
people um
to switch and so i will end there
and now i think we're going to open it
up for some
questions
great um thank you very much uh uh alex
thanks josh thank you mike and thanks
lynn
um so there are a bunch of questions
um but but maybe it would be good i
think there was enough
uh i don't say disagreement but i think
there were some
some some areas of little like uh
arguments that didn't exactly match up
among the panelists
so i just wanted to hear um if there are
any if there are any questions that the
panelists wanna or any issues or are
subjects that the panelists just wanna
kind of start with
uh given the very stimulating
presentations by each of the four
panelists
can i ask michael a question you sure
can
i just can can you just tell us the
difference in the
in the first rows of your 2016 voters
um what's the difference between those
first two rows
the the you mean from the two scenarios
yeah yeah yeah i just i missed so one
had the two point
damn advantage the other had the five
point yeah yeah so basically
the the edge cases right are that
the people who wrote oh i see um
came back and didn't change at all they
still voted 2.2
add that to the 22 points the 2018
voters were and you got 144 million
people
voting at 4.5 democratic or
they all come back and vote like they
did in 2018.
i gotcha one and then you get to seven
points
i gotcha i got okay great um
so there are a few questions about uh
polling and
the accuracy of polling and so i wanted
just to to ask um ask the panelists to
comment on that
i think alex alluded to the fact that uh
that there's a lot of waiting going on
in the polling
uh and alluded to response rate issues
um i i don't know that that um that that
everyone knows what the response rates
are on polls
one thing i say sometimes to folks is is
um do you remember if you had a very
good
high school statistics course you
learned about
the properties of a random sample from a
large population and how if you pull a
a relatively small random sample from a
large population
you're still able to get very accurate
estimates
of the underlying properties of that
large population
and so um so when you hear about the
the errors in the polls reported in the
media
that has absolutely nothing to do with
that
model you learned as a high school
student
you're not getting a random sample uh
from a
uh from a population it's really you're
getting
a lot of waiting going on to a
relatively small number of responses
but if if you could explain alex um what
you think uh
you know about the response rates and
the weighting and
and what role you think that played in
the issues with the polling uh
in this election
all right so uh as i said i'm not a
polling expert and so i i i
i understand that on this level the
people who respond to polls
are different from the electorate
we have the we have two problems we
don't know who they want to vote for and
we don't know whether they're going to
vote
so then we ask people who are going to
vote for and are you going to turn out
to vote
and then we need to say you're a kind of
person of this class
we know that there are so many of that
class in the population
and so then we're going to multiply your
answer
by the weight that we think you exist in
the overall
population so we're going to up weight
you by the proportion of
people who are like you in the
population and so we've got this problem
is do we know the kinds of people that
there are
and i think mike's point which is just
really interesting
here is what do we have what's the
problem
is that there's a type that we don't
have which is the trump voter who
doesn't take polls
and that person first of all we don't
know how many of them there are so it's
difficult to obtain
the amount by which we need to multiply
the thing
and the ones that we are able to get on
the phone are able to get to take the
yuga panel might be unlike
their brethren who who won't and so we
we don't know what to re-weight by so
mike also alluded to this idea that we
need to wait by
education that was the big explanation
for the 2016
polling failure is that oh we were
waiting by demographic variables like
age and gender what we needed to be
waiting by was how educated a person was
basically we weren't getting enough
people who had low levels of education
so we needed to take the people who had
low levels of education raised their
weights up in the survey and then we
would we would get the right answer
well we did that this round and we did
not get the right answer so
i think mike's like he's almost like
tautologically right evidently we didn't
get the
the the um the trump supporters
and this is the big problem to solve how
do we fix that problem
um lynn do you you you've been you've
had a lot of experience in polling
um i'd love to hear from mike but before
we do that i'd like to hear
hear from you um like what what kind of
response rates
um are are we getting these days uh for
polling
because that that gives us a sense of
what the the role of waiting is
uh uh oh they're super low they're super
low
you know a a traditional you know
random digit dial telephone pole which i
don't know if anybody does that anymore
but those kinds of
um not sampling off a list so you're
just trying to reach people
in some random way those are going to be
in the low single digits
if you're list based sampling you can be
a little higher than that but nobody is
getting
you know 50 no one's getting
30 percent um those are those are
miracle numbers
and so everybody is compensating and
i'll just say
two other things one is um you know you
really want to
people are waiting to 2016 vote which we
know
we know the outcome of 2016. and so
these posters are adjusting the sample
so that it gives them
the outcome of 2016 and they're still
wrong in 2020
okay so this isn't just that like we're
not finding trump voters
like we're finding republicans we're
finding republicans who voted for trump
we're making the sample
give us exactly what the outcome was in
2016 and it's still off by a lot
and so i think a huge culprit here is
getting the set of people right who are
eventually going to turn out in the
election
that has to be a huge part of how
wrong uh you know 2020 looks and that
would explain
uh i can't remember uh alex put up the
graph about how
the senate races are off like the
presidential races
if we've got the composition of the
electorate in 2020 wrong
um because more republicans turned out
than anybody thought ever would or
something like this
then then the polls are going to be off
in both those cases so that's that's a
leading a leading culprit great
the um i i slightly misspoke when i was
talking about
waiting i think there's the problem with
the low response rate i think is even if
you
uh get the observable demographics
correct it may be that
the individuals with those demographics
either
are you know are not representative of
the demographic you're trying to weight
everything up to
um mike or josh do you want to comment
on this i there are a lot of questions
about
about the polling and i i i just want to
make sure that that
we we uh discuss that matter a little
bit um
i have a few specific questions to
follow up with but yeah
and also about where do you where were
the errors largest why
why were they there what what other what
other issues would you like to
highlight yeah i'll dive in businesses
so
as right 16 here happens
like way off everybody like tries to
figure it out
because it was so consequentially off
right we just like didn't know
the campaign should be running and so
there was one effort which was sort of
public facing
which sort of came which like everybody
knows about because it's public basic
and there's a lot more research being
done
um but not public facing right
which led me to really understand just
how ridiculously impossible this problem
is
because even when you get down to
college non-college
um it is easy to see that the
the word don'ts mentioned and i'm like
not the academic saying it but it's all
about differential response bias right
that
some people are more or less likely to
take a survey actually i think i did
just say
that that's what i was trying to say i'm
like the
jargon the the but anyway the point is
that even you do collagen from college
if you turns out
if you are college in a college
neighborhood
you're different than college if you're
in a non-college neighborhood
if you're non-co and vice versa if
you're in college if you're
in college and you do manual work you're
way different than
if you're non-college and you are a
physician's assistant right and so by
thinking about something as broad as
non-college
is a sufficient proxy for the division
is sort of missing that the diff the
response bias isn't because you got a
college degree or not
it's all these other things that add up
to something else and
when you think about how to spend
especially because of the low response
rates how expensive is stupal
unless you do these online panels um
like the cost of correcting for these
things
in like the actual collection of the
data versus
fixing it at the back end is enormous
and so no one pays that price
right misleading a lot more phone cloud
a lot of stuff
that makes these polls too expensive to
to start to deal with that
and so it's like kind of uh like
just one of these things where you just
have to accept
that you have like um you are stuck with
a magnifying glass in a world that you
need a microscope
to see what's going on and you're just
not going to know
you're not going to know down to 3-4
points
what's actually happening because we
don't have a tool that does that anymore
great thank you thank you mike um so we
have a bunch of questions
i'm going to try and get to as many of
them as possible and we have about
um 15 or so minutes so
um so i would like you just sort of keep
that in mind
that i'm going to try and get through a
bunch of questions um
and i'd also like as many perspectives
on each question if there isn't
different perspective
so um so so okay keep that in mind
okay so here's here's some questions um
let's see
uh to what extent do you think the surge
in turnout in this election
is going to affect future rounds of
voting how persistent will this
increase in turnout be is there
something okay um alex
uh lin says not very okay alex please
well all i have to contribute on this
topic
is that we know that
when you turn out to vote in one
election you become
as a causal consequence of voting more
likely to vote in subsequence of
elections
we know this because of experiments like
professor gerber does where you induce
people to turn
out at random in one group and not
another and then
this persists for like 20 years we know
this for people who are
just 18 or just not 18 in one election
so they were ineligible the people who
were eligible to vote in the first
election are way more likely to vote in
subsequent elections
so we just got a huge treatment of a
whole bunch of people
turning out to vote for the first time
or you know a large number of people
turning out to vote for the first time
i think that that will have
habit-forming effects so lens thumbs
down notwithstanding i think that
there's some good reason to think that
it will persist
so we'll we'll actually see some local
elections soon and we'll see some things
to see if there's anything like that
uh mike please and then if josh has
something i can barely see see you josh
because of the questions
if you you want to lean actually if you
can lean right and then raise your
hand that would be great thank you so
this is like
particularly shocking for alan and josh
given
like the role i played with the animals
institute and like all the things
about gath but all of that is that the
what we saw was ecological right i mean
people voted this time around because
people were voting because as i said it
was the super bowl because everyone
people who were marginal voters saw
other people like them thinking this was
an important thing to do um
it was happening everywhere even where
and when i said before about like
campaign tactics don't matter
you go to a place in the middle of utah
where there's like nothing on the ballot
and people are voting at a higher rate
this year it had nothing to do
it had very little to do with
campaigning it had to do with the fact
that
voting was enormously socially salient
this time around
and when you take that um socially when
you take that
social salience out of it when you take
out the fact that you had
trump making politics the national sport
and you had the clearest decision ever
before american voters four more years
of that
or not yeah you're going to get insane
turnout and that's what we got
okay um can i add another yes
josh please please yeah so i think i
think alex does a really good job
summarizing what we know from
like past elections past social science
evidence that voting is
habit-forming but i think one
interesting wrinkle beyond what mike was
saying about four years of trump what
lynn was holding up about covet i think
another interesting ring
is just um half of
americans or so who vote in this
election don't trust the system they
don't trust the election results
and if you are a person who voted this
time around
as a kind of marginal voter who was
mobilized by donald trump
and then you feel your voice wasn't
heard you don't have trust in the system
you don't have faith in the system
you might not turn out and vote the next
time around the
kind of habit formation might not kick
in if you don't believe your vote was
valid to cast
um so i think we just kind of need to
wait to see whether or not 2020 was some
special year to which the kind of
voting is habit forming literature just
doesn't speak to you
great thank you josh so there's a
question related to that i know that
i'll read
um do you think turnout in the georgia
runoffs will be depressed
on gop side because trump isn't on the
ballot
and he's pressing the fraud narrative
making base voters think
uh why bother since it's rigged
any any thoughts about about that i will
say i don't think i
i don't think we'll help republicans in
georgia to be making those kind of
claims
um whether it's a large decrease or a
small decrease i i don't know
but but i would guess it's probably not
helpful to their
side other thoughts
i think other institutional features to
you know what's going on with the
pandemic in january
you know how is i don't actually don't
know if they're
you know how they're going to execute
this election will everybody get a mail
ballot
um i don't know what the what the
provisions are there but all those
things are going to affect
um turnout as well um
mike do you have anything you want to
add i by getting to sort of
continue to be contrarian on all this i
don't think that
um it's it's about like the social trust
part in going to vote
i think um the in this moment with trump
and like the division over sort of what
kind of america you live in
um it's more this is not about like
civics it's about identity
affirmation it's um you know
like going because your team is you know
at stake
and so the you know i think that
we we've literally been pulling every
night since the election
see the same thing that you're talking
about but
doesn't it it doesn't play in the logic
you're talking about
they still want to go out and um
you know affirm that the america they
want
um alex do you have anything to add or
okay um
so one other aspect of the georgia
runoff
is that it's taking place um you know i
i would think by the time
i think it's december 15th when people
can start um start voting if i if i
remember correctly
by that time um it's quite likely that
the
election will be more clearly even more
clearly resolved
um there's a in academic uh political
science
some folks are enamored with balancing
arguments
um which say that uh that voters or at
least some vote
some remember as you've all said
elections are decided by
a small number of voters going going d
versus
r r versus d uh some of those voters
um actually prefer policies kind of
toward the center
in which case they sometimes
vote for divided government do you think
there's anything to that argument in
general
and do you think it will play out at all
in in georgia
i wake up every day thinking about this
um
because well i do because it is so much
it hangs in the balance
of that was part of why i was interested
if you were still polling
like are people yes yeah yeah yeah it
sounds like mike is all suitable
yeah we we actually talked about trying
to add a question
about balancing um we ultimately decided
not to
but um you know and the political
scientist
in me wants to say you know that that
just
is that's not happening in a way that is
significant enough for us to be
concerned about but the realist in me
who is not a political scientist you
know wakes up in the morning and says
come on this has got to be
this has got to be playing a role for
some of these people on the margin
um and now whether those people turn out
like this is all very complicated like
if you
you're going to turn out because you
care aloud about your party and your
ideas and what michael just said the
world you want to live in
if if you're someone who's not that
committed to party and you might
switch over to vote for the other party
to give some balance like
maybe you're not motivated even to turn
out in this special election
on a day that you don't even know when
it's happening and etc etc so
i don't know um mike
yeah like probably that that's right
that pete the turnout's going to be
lower
um the like it's it's like
anti-climax in a lot of even though we
understand that it has greater political
significance
for people in georgia it's kind of an
anti-climax
and i don't know whether like which
i mean it's so close you don't know it's
crazy to say you know
plus or minus i just said you don't know
plus or minus two
and so i have no idea um but
they stay in that range
lynn can i ask you a question on this
kind of this swing voter question um
so like swing voters there's a very
small number of them
do we know anything about their
political knowledge like how many of
them even know
who controls the senate like that seems
like a prerequisite in order to have
this balancing take place like
are they yeah i know that the senate is
kind of like depends on this georgia
race
like super interesting and and obviously
critical piece of information if you're
gonna try to balance
um and it is it is true like what you're
saying is
people without a party identification
people
who don't know who they're gonna vote
for until the very end of an election
on average i'm not saying everybody who
fits into this category but on average
um these people know less about politics
they
maybe don't know who controls the senate
they don't know how many people around
the supreme court et cetera et cetera
um and and that if you just think about
that for two seconds it makes
sense if you if you were someone who was
invested
in politics you probably would lean
toward one party or the other
um especially when nudged twice um
maybe not the first time maybe not but
you know eventually you'd say okay yeah
like i'm one or the other
so so i always say like these people
have a dictionary for politics
that is just a little bit off they don't
it doesn't translate very well
for them the way it does uh for people
who are more engaged
there's a a saturday night live sketch
about the
independent voters and the questions
demanding
candidates answer and i think the
questions are who's running
uh is the first the first of the
questions
okay um so i okay so let's see
uh okay um this isn't i just i'm gonna
start going through these relatively
rapidly um how long do you think it's
going to take for the country to get rid
of the
eight legacy of the trump years um again
it's a nonpartisan panel
i'm just reading the questions but uh
but i think
i think i think that you know that's a
question so what what are the
what are the views
do you think this is do you think trump
is leaving depends on elite
and what is it and what does it depend
on that's the question my answer is
it depends on elites it depends on
candidates and what they choose to talk
about
and and raise uh to a level of
importance for voters
so i'm going to be like strenuously
uh more pessimistic right because
the if there may have been a moment when
elites could do that
when mccain could say he's a christian
but trump has demonstrated a path to
winning republican
primaries that
take that that notice that the majority
of republican voters
do not want that right that you you win
republican primaries by not being that
and so there's like no room for
republican those that kind of republican
elite right now
because you it's just that's that's what
we're stuck with
um and that's what's going to bind the
be the boundary for them
they're not going to do that okay next
question
um i've seen some exit polls that
believe swing voters
tend to view republicans as more focused
on the economy
and democrats more focused on social
issues
is this something democrats should
address
um okay the basically
the my answer to anything that question
that begins with the word exit poll
is not want to answer the question
um because they're like just crazy wrong
um
and we had two exit polls this time one
said
uh that um trump won
uh white uh college women uh
women by one point and that biden won
them by 20.
um and you know the exits
you know last the rat time around said
seniors were 16
of the population now of the vote it's
just like all crazy wrong
like crazy demonstrably wrong okay so
friendly amendment to the question i
think is
like some some people think that swing
voters
or some some people are concerned that
from as a political matter
republicans are are being given
the brand of being concerned about the
economy
whereas democrats are being given the
brand as being concerned about social
issues
is this something the democrats should
address or it you know what do you what
do you think of that
that framing and is this something again
i'm just i'm trying to
frame the question i think like these
kinds of short this
these kinds of shortcuts are they happen
all the time
um and it's natural for people to want
to do them this is the party of this and
this is the party of that
but if you're really if the question the
person asks the question is really
concerned about the economy
all i would say is like i just showed
you a graph of the
actual output of the nation's economy
people get it
like when the economy is growing they
re-elect the incumbent so
if that's what you're worried about that
republicans are always going to win
because people always want a good
economy
that is not what's happening okay
um do the panelists agree with westwood
at al
um that the uh forecasts
along with that the polling forecasts um
disproportionately depressed democratic
turnout
eg 538 creating its own weather so
do we yeah
do you think polling had any effect any
material effect on voter behavior
no not in terms of turnout i i i could
yeah i could believe in 16 some people
voted third party
because they didn't like clinton or
either way
again they thought they knew the outcome
but actually
the difference between like voting for
against someone
is like an opinion inside your head
going out to votes of behavior
and like you're doing it for lots of
other reasons
other thoughts okay um
what caused the time along with solomon
messing where they
randomized um minimize whether
the the election is being described as a
win probability
or as like the vote margin and people
get these two things very much confused
and so then they have a survey outcome
that suggests
that people are less worried about the
election when they
see it as a win probability i found that
that survey experimental part of it
quite compelling actually you asked the
question better than i did i i
i didn't understand that part of the
question thank you
thank you very much alex okay um what
caused higher
the high voter turnout of both democrats
and republicans in this election
like what do you think the key factors
were a key factor
no the key factor was that like
the future of the world was at stake and
every
and everybody you know have to listen to
politics every day for four years
um so right i mean
that's different from the last 250 years
i'd say the proximity of the 2016
outcome just how razor raises or close
it was
and then how surprising it was to a lot
of people and then the ease with which
a lot of people were able to vote this
time um because of
vote by mail and the constant constant
constant commentary
about filling out your ballot i mean it
was just it was
just impossible not to be hit with that
all those things probably contribute
um if polls under sample trump
supporters
is an inference from that that trump's
approval rating
has been underestimated all along as
well
sure okay i don't i don't know that it's
clear that we're under sampling trump
voters by the way just
it but yes the point is well taken that
was like half an hour ago and it's it's
we only have one minute left and
i mean if
like never comes up in this conversation
that's really important right is that
the the polling right is only trying to
get
um what like some sense of america
thinks
but that's not always identical to the
people who show up for the election
right and they're not really the same
thing
right so that probably if you could do a
like a census of america the
like trump's approval would be really
horrible um
and a census of america and the election
is like there's a lot of room in between
great okay um we're coming to very close
to the end of our time together
um each of you if you if you could you
have uh one more thought you'd like to
share with us
um before we we depart
collected more results come in and i
think stay tuned to to really learn more
about the 2020 election since
everything we're saying now everything
you're hearing in the media just like
it's preliminary
and and you really need to wait and be
patient for all the results to come in
yeah okay out go ahead
i i i'll i saw a lot of questions in the
q a
about the texas uh and the latino vote
down there and i'll
share one little piece of analysis i
looked at yesterday we were using our
data collection because we have almost
500 000 interviews
we have a lot of interviews with people
from very different national origins
so hispanic ethnicity with different
national origins so we were looking at
uh mexican national origins to mexican
americans in texas
you can see that big shift um toward
uh trump but then we said well those
counties are small and they're
they're unusual in their size texas a
lot of counties
um those border counties are small
counties almost
all uh hispanic population what if
what about the mexican americans in
louisiana and mississippi and other
conservative states
who don't make up their own county so
we're not seeing the county shift
and so we just looked and they were also
um have you know heavily trump
59 trump um and so one
thing to remember when you think about
counties is those are sort of arbitrary
drawn geographic units they're not the
same in every state
um and so that might not be about you
know
border counties in texas it might be
about mexican americans in conservative
leaning states
and in texas they happen to make up
their own geographic unit
mike i just said like you know what josh
said but also
not only wait until like at least
february march to
like have a prayer of understanding
what's going on what the kind of
questions you want
if someone tells you the answer to a
question you actually care about
they're telling you what they thought
before the election
and found some data point that someone
threw out somewhere to
validate it um and that's all you just
gotta roll with it
great and and one last question i i i
just like to ask this
uh of folks uh not is there
is there a an article a website
a book something that you have read
recently or some source of information
that you go to
to learn something about about politics
that you would share with uh share with
the audience because the anyone who's
who's made it all the way through to the
end of an hour and 15-minute panel
um they um they might want to learn some
more uh so
so what would you uh what would you
recommend uh just got
i just got edward tufty's new book he's
a political science professor at yale
right so like it counts
yes it sure does
alex didn't alex didn't get his last
observation
definitely
yeah he didn't he didn't he didn't take
a take me up on it
uh other other uh sources of information
that you would recommend
like for more info you know articles
that you've read that are
especially insightful or interesting
well i've already pitched
lynn's book the message matter and
allen's book get out the vote
but the third source that i'll point to
in all seriousness is i think
nate cohen at the upshot probably does
some of the best selection analysis
public facing election analysis and
his twitter feed i think is a really
fantastic resource
great thank you um if you like the
day-to-day
if you like the day-to-day inside scoop
of what's going on the
politico playbook um that is
every morning delivered to your inbox is
but that's really for the people who
want to deep dive
uh mike yeah i'll just review what i
said before if you didn't read anything
for the last four years you'd had a
better idea of what hat was going to
happen on november 3rd thank
you read what anybody else had written
perfect okay well thank you all thank
you you're you're amazing uh amazing
panelists
uh it was a wonderful uh of you to
take time out of your um your evenings
to spend
to spend with uh with us and to give us
your insights
um please visit the isps website
isps yale.edu
to keep up with isps events and research
and look for announcements of future
events
if you would like you could join our
mailing list to receive a monthly
newsletter see the website for more
details
with that i i thank you all for spending
the time with us this evening
and i hope to see you at future isps
events
uh good evening to you all bye-bye
you